back at it with the supernatural
conventions today because greg and john
got some
new shirts uh we're gonna watch from
supernatural conventions smolders
regrets and hotel
room doors thank you so much for putting
this together
guys over at our patreon page we have
made it to supernatural
season six only one more season left to
go and then we're fully caught up on the
series i think that's the way it goes
seven seasons i appreciate everyone who
has shown their support by becoming a
patronage
it's meant a hell of a lot it's been one
hell of a journey over there we cover a
lot of tv shows where we have the option
for reaction highlights and
watch alongs where you sync up with the
time code all at the same tier for many
shows such as supernatural
doctor who just started up avatar the
last airbender and then a whole bunch of
other shows my god
look at the thumbnails thumbnails galore
over here
because there's so many tv shows that we
cover
my god and music videos sometimes even
including
jensen ackles performances
[Music]
so um
yes
who is the closest to you guys
he will now be on walker
you know these really uh fancy consoles
they actually have courses
that deal with green screen acting or
reacting to
uh an imaginary universe or imaginary or
something
reading the dialogue that's
it's mostly scar that is
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so we're shooting an episode of
supernatural uh this was
i i think it might have been season four
season four or five
and there's this table there's this
table we're in an operating room there's
a
there's a there's a heart on the table i
remember and i
uh jared and jensen are standing on one
side of the table and i approach
and i have my dialogue and i come up to
the table and i'm saying my dialogue
and and jared has a broomstick in his
hand under the table and he finds
finds my crotch which is hard to find by
the way
[Laughter]
[Applause]
parenting 101 full disclosure
just disclosure man if we don't have
parenting 101 trending
we failed so every take he's like doing
that and then they then the
first lady takes the boomer away from
him and then on subsequent takes
he's just like making faces at me when i
come up i
one of my special skills on my resume is
not not laughing
when someone does something while i'm on
camera so i was messing up every take
the director was getting angry because
he didn't see what jared was doing
and jensen stepped up and he said hey
man don't even look at him
just look at me just look at me
i was like thank you [ __ ] thank you
for that lifeline
like one person he did that and so we
did the next take and i come up and i
look at jensen and he goes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
fish in a barrel stuff writes itself so
look at me
look at me
[Music]
[Music]
mixed with tomato paste
[Music]
you should try it very nice
vegetarian ground sausage
disgusting really works really really
gross this sort of
turned into a paste in my mouth and um
yeah it's not a fond memory
really tall sorry i know the feeling
how really he doesn't
[Laughter]
sorry mark um pretty sorry mark
yeah do you know what they did to me
last week we took a picture right
there's a four
or four shot of us so should we show
this and show them what's the worst
picture ever right
this is what they do to me so we started
we put him next to me
get ready for the photography
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i'm the only one who didn't spot it of
course
until i get five minutes he's like wait
a second but
are you all on your tip toes or we're
like and by the way we didn't even
discuss it before it happened
automatically that's my life my wife is
six feet tall so
i feel that yeah yeah it's a beautiful
thing two girls are special
and tall boys not so much tall girls are
special
and your question is for misha
um okay i gotta remember my question
um day one you had a resume
before supernatural years later is there
any special skills you could say you've
added since then
it's breaking wind or special skill
science farting
well there's certainly some i need to
scratch off
[Laughter]
really you can it's with like
kinkos and and uh fedex or whatever
you could just devour your old resume
and come up with a whole new one
i mean just in all the days of your
lives oh do it
oh my dude
[Applause]
i mean that's true and i'll wait till
you know friday probably the 13th and
then
and i'll just get it all done and just
go vacation in a christmas car or
somewhere
it'll take a new york minute
he's throwing himself under the bus
he's like wait i got to throw myself
under her eyes
uh yeah just maybe maybe somewhere nice
somewhere near stonehenge
oh yeah yeah yeah i heard the apocalypse
was there man i don't wanna
in all honesty i think that the habits
i've learned probably
i'll probably never work again you know
that the american government
fly do you know that the american
government actually hired jared to break
into iphones
[Laughter]
that's right the fbi is trying to get
apple and then like i can't get in we
can't get in
call paddling he steals your phone and
while he looks like oh yeah i love this
picture
he's tweeting i hate my fans i pick my
nose
[Applause]
i think my booger is a couple of special
skills that i'd put on um
that that apparently not a lot uh
hitting a mark
uh remembering my lines
um those are apparently special skills
in our industry these days
i would certainly [ __ ] hope so i've
never used it
i've never used those who needs lines
mark's still trying to learn
hey guys i just want to see your you've
been doing it for 11 years you're cw
smolders
[Applause]
wasn't she on uh how i met your mother
i know it's kobe smulders we call it we
call it
we actually we we have it it's called
the labored
inhale one two
three
[Laughter]
can i can i just can i just briefly
sidebar there that reminds me
of the first year that i went to the
upfronts with you guys and you guys had
at that point absolutely perfected the
cw smolder yeah so
we got up can we just do one more
demonstration
we got up to the like red carpet to do
the shots and it was like this
[Applause]
and you didn't know until the next day
when you see all this [ __ ] online you're
like
what was i doing why didn't no one tell
me
that
there's also like the decidedly like
pointedly casual glance to the back of
your shoe where you're like
as if like did i step on something yeah
or did somebody ask me a question
[Laughter]
no that's a classic that's a tv classic
i still don't think it's fair that
that's called the smolder but that's
just me um
uh thank you uh let's go burn indeed
just a little morning
[Applause]
[Music]
you couldn't say nothing
but that was not my question
do either of you ever look back um kind
of in retrospect
what'd she say
[Applause]
uh more so uh i i have that
those kind of reflected moments about uh
well jared's performances
the terrible part of television is a lot
of times you get
like a preparation and sometimes you're
doing like the end
we did a series we did a stretch of like
12 episodes
and season four or five were literally
the first day of shooting we filmed the
last episode
[Music]
you haven't read um script
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he was reading it
[Applause]
what'd you uh for me
it's often just about you know like i'll
i'll watch
uh a scene and i can see the corners of
my mouth
i wish i was able to more properly
sabotage other actors other than
michelle
yeah like you can take me down
so easy that's what she says
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank you
and you were like no they're still on
stage
i'll take the stage like here's the
scene and the set and then we were
outside
and then we had to pull on go like back
to our trailer
[Laughter]
robin props was standing there reading
your lines and next to her uh was tammy
and tammy's like super short and that
was jensen
and robin was reading the lines like
this but holding her hand
[Applause]
[Music]
people go out a little later than normal
here
[Music]
so we all went to our respective floors
and
i went to my room and put the key in
back in the elevator back down to the
lobby mikey doesn't work
here trying to keep thank you back up
the door open
nothing key
[Music]
so i go back downstairs i'm like no
working
so he comes up with his master key and
he nothing
[Music]
yeah keep in mind it's late it's after
midnight
because i'm tired and i know i gotta get
up
and and put on a show for you guys
because that's why we're here and that's
what we love to do
and
[Applause]
so he's like i'm sorry
i woke um so maintenance guy comes up
with his own tool belt and he basically
does the exact same thing that we've
been doing
puts the key in puts the key in
i'm like yes we've established that it's
not working
how do we get it to work i don't that is
it
that they're required to do this are we
going to have the economy
um well that's not going to work for me
[Music]
the front desk guy is like we will get
you into
the present teaching suite like i don't
care about the president
i want to get into my room and i want to
get into it now
so that i can go to bed and wake up and
go to work
there's no things that we can do today
uh i'm so sorry
um what did you let us do
get into my room and i'm like listen
if you can't get into my room i will get
into my room
and he's like i'm sorry
i said are you saying that you cannot
open this door
is that yes it's impossible okay
i'm gonna keep the door right
[Applause]
and he just goes okay
[Music]
and i was like that's all i needed
walked over
slid the furniture that was in the
hallways step back
boom
damn
it exploded the door
and let the hole in it like this big
it was it was basically the entire
mechanism of the locking mechanism
i thought the door would swing open and
then the door jamb would have broken but
no the entire
lock could handle the iron plate that it
was on
going through the door
and uh
you're gonna need a new door
open the door swung open nice and free
get close to the big jet hole in it and
i went to bed
[Music]
at that point i didn't care some lucky
guests
i mean i you know i give it to the staff
there they did
honestly i don't think it ever crossed
their mind
that that the big texan standing before
them was going to murder their hotel
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm not quite sure i understand what
you're saying to
but i didn't wait i didn't wait for him
to figure it out i just uh
i just destroyed the door so uh so long
story short his favorite part of being
on the show is learning important life
skills
do you think that if you get kicked down
doors all the time on the show
that that that idea would have ever
crossed your mind i'm like i don't think
it would have
but we kick down doors all the time i'm
like
this is obviously the progression of
things to do
you try the key if it does not work you
try
a maintenance man if that doesn't work
you break the freaking door down
[Music]
you're gonna be the new door
and see
we talked for two minutes per video
so don't know what this lie is you're
spreading here it's false advertising is
what that
is i got a question for you ash when you
put together these videos and you have
this end graphic for us which we are
incredibly grateful for which i'm i'm
always flattered to read
do people ever go what
[Laughter]
[Music]
all of your spn related videos reference
these
what do they have to do with the show
and this password you thank you
i think jensen ackles being a texan
would have broken down that door
regardless
from whatever stereotypes i know about
texans
that's what i'm gonna conclude it's just
the instincts that rise from the pit
of the texans stomach and if jared
patalecki had been drinking
he would have just head-butted that door
open we know
that much and then he'd fallen asleep in
the doorway it would have been a great
time
that was a great story that story is in
record i forgot who someone at our
patreon
sent me that video specifically of a
hotel like oh yeah i've been
keeping me watched for months and i just
never have i was actually really glad to
hear because that is a really funny
story
i would be i would be incredibly cranky
and mad and i wouldn't be able to sleep
after that
i don't know how he was able to sleep i
don't care how tired you are i would
have been so
my pulse would have been up i would have
been furious with the treatment i would
have thought about how i'm not getting
any sleep now i would just be thinking
about all the sleep i missed dealing
with this problem
it would it would have bugged me all
night and i wouldn't have slept and that
would just spend my whole day angry
says more about me when i'm talking
about me only and how i would feel
doesn't it yeah well no i mean i would
be the maintenance man in there with
like the car just going i don't know
i don't know you try this
and they just don't believe you plug
that into when you get somebody else to
come help and there's that moment of
like oh good the maintenance man and
then the maintenance man isn't even
going to do maintenance
yeah you're going to try the normal
stuff that you would always try but a
badass story shows and moves make it
look easy to kick open a door it's not
it's not
believe it or not i've tried it it's not
it's so much thicker especially a hotel
room door
which is going to have some strength man
yeah i want to kick like the whole
locking mechanism through the doors
and he said it was one kick in movies
and shows so it's usually three kicks
yeah for like a big moment one two then
the third one
gets the job done dope trope gotta write
that down
we'll schedule it in
mighty impressive on his end and even
more impressive that they just let him
go to sleep after
that yeah i'm just not gonna this didn't
lead to a lawsuit or something
i know it's like granted that was pretty
messed up on their end at the same time
you know they were trying their best for
what it sounded like
and he gave but i imagine like that must
have been a hefty bill
yeah you got the language barrier too
although you know in these cases i have
to imagine that they're also
people who deal with this so maybe
jensen himself doesn't actually have to
deal with the aftermath perhaps there's
somebody from
you know the network who deals with this
well knowing jensen he probably fixed
the door himself
yeah he built a new dory mechanism from
scratch
he installed it all with that texas
know-how
and learned it all from the show all the
things you learned from the show
all those skills yeah there were some
great tidbits here
general things that some of them were
talking about jared padilecki and misha
how they were talking about filming out
of order and how that can be
very tough you used to constantly hear
actors who come from feeder
say that they felt like that's more real
acting because you go from beginning to
end you're not doing
retakes so you're really feeling the
whole story from beginning to end and
then some actors
do prefer film because you could really
digest and dive into a whole
scene you know that's where a great
editor comes into play to make you
make you look like this is one fluid
storytelling with your performance on
top of everything else but you do gotta
really do script examination on that on
your end as an actor to be able to
make sure that if you're filming the
last scene first that everything else is
coming before it you know and
also without not fully preparing how
you're going to do a scene
exactly when it comes to okay i have to
shoot
an earlier scene in this story tomorrow
or a few days from now but you know i
don't want to seem like a stiff
performer
too much of a pre-planned performer it's
still going to feel natural i feel like
that's probably a
common thing that people often have to
deal with is filming out of order and
how tough that can actually be
yeah you know yeah definitely i mean
especially i would imagine in tv and
network tv where you know sometimes
you're starting a shoot monday morning
and you don't have the script done
sunday night
sometimes like i've seen this happen
before where yeah like late in the night
you'll get the script and then you start
your prep
and it's you know up to at a certain
point the writers to get that stuff to
you on time
and uh and it makes me wonder what kind
of ship supernatural had with the
writer's room and getting the scripts to
everybody and how much
rewriting would have been done because
yeah like if you have to go
and immediately start off your shoot
with the most you know emotionally heavy
climactic scene
in ways i would imagine you can apply
that to the other stuff you're shooting
but you know it's
you can't bring that into a prior moment
yeah you know as if you're anticipating
it in your performance so like the
level of compartmentalization i imagine
that exists on a show like this has to
be pretty formidable
at the same time though you know knowing
these guys and how
long they've been living these
characters even by this point of the
episode that they're
specifically referencing i remember i
once heard a story about how kelsey
grammer and fraser have been playing
frasier for so long
that he would kind of just you know
learn his lines a day of
and just go into it because he just
knows the character so well by this
point that it didn't really
he doesn't have to do all this extra
homework in order to
really nail the performance so i bet
like on on a first season it's really
rough but by the time you really get to
know your character i imagine that you
can just go in there and just seem very
natural because you know your character
in and out how they be in this
in that moment yeah it's just more about
you know having to really factor in the
previous stuff because i know misha
makes that jab towards jared about like
well you didn't read the script yeah
at the same time though you know it's
like you actors are constantly
discovering things
in the middle of either rehearsing or in
the middle of actually filming they'll
discover something about
this scene uh this emotional note that
might come out of them spontaneously
so i can imagine a scenario where you
you are doing a
a scene that's prior to the the final
scene and then you're like oh man if i
had known this part of me would come out
or
or my the actor who i'm in the scene
with was gonna do
this i might have played that later
scene
a little different you know which i i
can imagine can be frustrating
especially when you're watching yourself
and you can probably pick up on all
those little things that you know that
the audience is not able to tell but you
know you're just like
just keep beating yourself up but i feel
like for creative types every time you
look back at any work you've done you're
probably gonna think
i could have done this better i could
have done this different no matter what
it is
yeah yeah and i thought that was you
know it's like asking that question or
hearing somebody ask that question i had
to sit there and think
they probably have ton like just more
moments than you could ever
describe to somebody that you would have
wanted differently or improve upon or
change
given some other piece of context or
information but i think it too
i mean you can see in these conventions
especially in the core cast but even
more especially just between jared and
jensen i have to imagine that having
that real life rapport too like i don't
know exactly what their relationship is
like but it seems like they have a
certain amount of that brotherly
chemistry in real life and i have to
imagine that
whatever telepathic link that creates
can also create an extra level of
comfort when it comes to
you know being in that position and it's
funny because it made me think of
uh misha because i i felt for him in
that moment it was a really funny story
but the whole thing about jensen coming
to him and being like look
just look at me and i'll support you for
the scene and then immediately on the
next take he's screwing with them too
yeah i also think that maybe having that
level two of like okay i gotta be on top
of it because if the camera's not on
anybody
else you know they're gonna be doing
something else maybe so it puts the onus
on i think each
performer to really have those roots too
you know
so much of the stories are about messing
with misha you know they all mess with
each other who's the guy plays crowley
mark mark sheppard shepard mark shepard
yeah okay so mark sheppard yeah they
mess with him too but he seems like he's
probably
really good at ripping it down you know
he seems like he
i mean like they all seem like they
enjoy it but he seems like he would be
like oh game on
yeah yeah yeah because he's already got
it seems like from the way he behaves on
stage as well as in the show that that
sort of like
secure and impish quality to him is is a
real one
but with misha specifically it seems
like they really
love to mess with him it makes me think
of a couple things because one is
i imagine that having that level of
loose
environment is actually really good and
it can be actually really helpful even
in a very dramatic scene that you're
trying to do or an intense kind of
performance
because it loosens you up to express
yourself so i it's some might think it's
kind of contradictory
i know with british actors they're often
people who will constantly just you know
not take each other that seriously in
the most heavy of scenes yeah
because it does create kind of a playful
environment a willingness to really play
around and so that
it opens you up and frees you up even in
a really serious
environment you know there's a certain
line you can cross where you're not
where you're just being completely
disrespectful
especially if someone has to like cry
like i can imagine that that big
monologue scene where dean is talking
about you know being in hell and all
these have to do
and if jared paddle lucky was messing
with him then i'd imagine that is not
helpful
you know he's getting mad at that point
so it's not a black and white scenario
but i imagine for a lot of it it can be
helpful but what's funny to me about the
dynamics that i'm constantly picking up
on with them misha collins is currently
46. jared padalecki 38
jensen ackles is 42. you know hearing
the ages of jensen ackles and jared
padalecki and knowing that supernatural
has been on for so long i thought they'd
be like way closer to 50.
they'd be so much children
there's so much other work they can do
still that's 17 seasons of water that
is crazy how much more how much more
fuel must be left in their tank but
misha collins is older than them but yet
they
treat him like a younger brother that
they pick on you know that they make fun
of a lot he gives it back to them often
too
it's just funny to me the dynamic of
he's he's definitely older than them
yet they treat him like he's the younger
sibling all the time and it does really
come across that way
because also i think too you know you
have i mean misha collins is reasonably
tall but jared and jensen are like a
million feet tall and i think that story
about them doing the red carpet with me
should just be like i'm gonna smile
while these do do their thing
like he really does feel like the
youngest brother in the sense that like
these two have their simpatico rapport
and then miesha's almost like not in a
in a mean or a nasty way but he's like
the amusing odd one out
in their trio and that creates a whole
other dynamic of fun
and free yeah man they got that cw
smolder down perfect oh my god
i love when they're so i think their
self-awareness really shines through
in their performances too whenever
they're doing a really comedic scene or
even that episode with the with the
trickster and the televisions
and like the one division episode
essentially yeah
that episode um that self-awareness that
they have
can really shine through in their
comedic scenes especially but when you
see them on these interviews
and uh these conventions and stuff i i
love when they just
make fun of themselves naming off all
their credits and
stuff like that supernatural conventions
this was another fun one to cover
thank you again ash hey subscribe to
supernatural conventions channel
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell to get
notified whenever we got a new youtube
video up check us on patreon where we of
course
covering supernatural last but not least
let's do it
i'd like to chat on a man named david
gandonader david gandy
my god what a journey you and i have
been on together so far
i know in the bay area it was really on
fire recently so i hope your health
is all right i know that you've had one
hell
of a really it's a testing year i'll say
that
it's been a testing year for you we've
all had to deal with it in some way with
the whole covet situation
outside of that though i i mean and
you've had to do a lot
it seems like though that you have
managed to enhance your character
throughout all this you have managed to
grow and strengthen yourself i am very
much
impressed with an individual such as
yourself who can still further develop
his creative talents
build a stronger foundation within you
your
wisdom seems to constantly amplify so
i'm really happy to know you man
you are a treasure in my life i love
the f word out of your [ __ ] so thank you
so much
you are special to me in every way love
you buddy
love you i don't think you watch
supernatural so you will get this
message
at the end of the month when we post it
on patreon
on which video you got your shout out on
hope you enjoy three and a half weeks
later
after our friendship has entirely
crumbled due to certain events
that have happened damn you david damn
you
why would you betray us like that and
take
your whole pledge over to tyrone
magnus's patreon oh wow
i think we post one video more than him
a month
what the hell